la parole est à antoine lefèvre pour le
groupe union pour un mouvement populaire
merci
madame la présidente monsieur le premier
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à madame la garde des
sceaux ministre de la justice madame la
garde des sceaux je veux revenir sur ce
qu'a publié hier leur site atlantico le
désherber célèbre mur des cons intro
bino scop de responsables politiques de
droite principalement de syndicalistes
policiers de haut magistrat le
journaliste voir ce collage murale
d'hommes politiques de droite comme de
gauche y compris votre collègue de
l'intérieur monsieur valls en dit long
d'ailleurs sur les rapports police
magistrats mais que fais tu fais plus
consternant figurent des parents de
victimes de récidivistes
l'une violer et tuer par guy georges
l'autre tuée de 34 coups de couteau dans
un rer ses parents meurtris dans leur
chaire en commis la faute alors suprême
milité contre la récidive ce qui leur
vaut aux yeux de certain de figurer sur
son mur de la honte vous avez répondu
hier à mon collègue luc chatel aucune
entrave ne sera faite aux procédures que
les personnes visées engagerait c'est
encore heureux la présidente du syndicat
auteurs de ce mur scandaleux parle de
défouloir de blague de potache mais dans
cette affaire nous ne sommes pas en
présence de lycéens ou d'étudiants à
l'humeur potache ni même à l'école de la
magistrature
nous sommes dans les locaux d'un
syndicat professionnel deux juges dont
on attend une impartialité exemplaires
une catégorie professionnelle comme
celle de la magistrature censée être la
plus neutre de la république ne peut se
permettre de s'enfermer dans une
idéologie politique car c'est ce dont
nous parlons ici elle doit juger de
façon équitable
la dérive de ce syndicat pose question
notre propos n'est pas de stigmatiser la
justice en général mais le comportement
de certains qui semble oublier l'essence
même de leur indépendance dont ils sont
si jaloux et que vous ne cessez de nous
rappeler madame la garde des sceaux cela
ne peut que susciter questionnement sur
leur impartialité ne vaut-il pas la
porte à une légitime suspicion c'est la
confiance que placent en eux la société
qui est ainsi ébranlé cela laisse planer
de dangereux augure sur les propositions
du président de la république désireux
de donner plus d'indépendance encore au
conseil de la magistrature
ce que vous avez qualifié d' action
malheureuse madame la garde des sceaux
est en fait une faute grave le ministère
public peut prendre l'initiative d'une
action publique je vous cite alors
madame la garde des sceaux je vous le
demande faites le et faites le de façon
très claire je vous remercie
merci ses collègues la parole est à
christiane taubira garde des sceaux
ministre de la justice madame la
présidente mesdames dessinatrice
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur lefebvre vous devriez me citer
complètement parce que vous savez que
j'ai dit à votre collègue de
l'opposition à l'assemblée nationale que
je trouve cet acte inadmissible je peux
ajouter qu'il est insupportable je peux
mais a ajouté qu'il est stupide et
malsain et il est temps que le syndicat
de la magistrature se rendent compte que
la période stupide et malsaine est passé
et qu'ils n'ont pas besoin qu'ils n'ont
pas besoin effectivement de prendre des
risques sur l'image de neutralité de la
magistrature j'ai comme vous sans doute
le souci de distinguer le corps de la
magistrature ces magistrats qui exercent
leurs mission de juger noble mission au
quotidien avec dignité de ceux qui se
sont livrés à cet acte qui se sont
abaissées à se livrer à cet acte ceci
étant dit vous savez bien qu'en qualité
de garde des sceaux moi même je ne peux
pas méconnaître la loi et qu'on ne peut
considérer comme une faute disciplinaire
un acte commis dans un local syndical
est révélée par des images volées
j'ai saisi le conseil supérieur de la
magistrature pour lui demander s'il peut
apprécier sylvia manquement à la
déontologie
ce syndicat a pris des risques sur
l'ensemble du corps de la magistrature
et notamment sur ses propres membres à
en juger par les menaces de récusation
sur les procédures en cours
c'est dommageable à l'ensemble du corps
j'espère que nous en sortirons parce que
ce qui est important c'est
qu'effectivement notre magistrature
retrouve sa noblesse que nous puissions
la débarrasser du soupçon qui pèse sur
son impartialité et que leur relation
soit éclairci entre le corps de la
magistrature et l'exécutif